freedom day today is what we've been
told um are you veering more towards
uh elation or trepidation
for the days and weeks ahead i think
look
throughout this um pandemic we have
faced different challenges
and the vaccination program has
demonstrated
this country's ability to rise to that
challenge incredible coming together the
nhs our armed forces local government
the private sector 80 000 vaccinated
volunteers came out of retirement
um ba staff joining the vaccinated
army um and of course uh many many
hundreds of thousands others who
volunteered to usher people through the
vaccination
centers we all want to return to
normality
this is a a virus that is highly
infectious respiratory disease virus
aerosol transmitted
so we have to be careful we have to
remain vigilant our border controls
remain in place
our expectation and recommendation that
people
in crowded places continue to
wear masks and take both personal and
corporate responsibility
in doing so and it's great to see tfl
and others uh doing that so
it is step four it's an important step
uh there is no perfect time to take this
step
this is as good a time as any as chris
whittie has said with the summer
holidays and schools being out which
will hopefully
bear down on the r number the
transmission rate
so i'm confident that we're doing the
right thing almost 88
just shy of that 87 uh
i have now had the protection of one
dose and 68
of all adults have the protection of two
doses so
um i think the vaccination program has
allowed us
to take this step take it cautiously uh
with this wall of protection
of adults in the united kingdom okay
that was a very long answer wasn't it to
my question i'm not sure you answered it
though elation or trepidation for the
weeks ahead
um cautious optimism is probably the way
i would describe it
um i hope that helps kay that's a
shorter answer
and i hope you can leave it at that
before you get before you go any further
uh you talked about masks uh we heard
prince charles saying he doesn't want to
wear a mask and camilla is not going to
wear a mask are you going to wear a mask
so i will wear a mask in crowded
indoor spaces i will wear a mask if i'm
on a
a train carriage that is crowded because
not only will it
obviously protect myself but it'll
protect others around me i don't know if
someone sitting next to me
is immuno suppressed or you know
compromised
and to put them at risk unnecessarily
with a virus that i know transmits very
very
effectively through aerosol transmission
it's a respiratory disease
highly transmissible so i would
absolutely wear a mask in crowded places
okay so so the future king is wrong then
to say that he doesn't want to wear a
mask
no i think look um the guidance are
clear
in indoor crowded places it's the right
thing to do is to wear masks and it's
recommended
and we are asking people to take
responsibility and
of course organizations whether it's tfl
or others to take corporate
responsibility
the supermarkets have come out around uh
how they want
their customers to behave in the
supermarkets this is important
you know we all want to go back to
normal but part of going back to normal
is having to deal with some of these
difficult situations and i think it's
right that individuals
and corporations and yeah public
institutions
do that and think it through by doing
the right thing we've got to control
uh and transition this virus from
pandemic to endemic
as i think we will begin to do so with a
booster campaign in this in september as
well which we can talk more about
questions should we we've got lots to
get through including this
pesky pandemic 1.7 million people
are presently self isolating you are
looking at trying to change that
for some people who work for the nhs
explain that to me simply if you will
because i was reading it this morning
it's a bit complicated
yeah no absolutely okay so for nhs
frontline and social care staff
who have had the alert if they are
double vaccinated
then they can work with their employer
um
to take a pcr test and if they are
negative then they can go back to work
without having to
self-isolate being careful being
precautionary
not being close to people who are
extremely vulnerable
to the virus but this will allow the nhs
and social care
to cope as we of course transition this
virus as i say from from pandemic status
to endemic status
so it's the additional way of helping
the nhs
uh and social care to do that for those
staff who are double vaccinated from
when
so we've announced it today um so it
begins um
for immediately uh for them to to to
begin to
uh be able to if they are double
vaccinated go back to work without
having
to isolate it of course they have to
take a pcr test and that has to be
negative if it's positive they have to
obviously then
uh uh uh isolate for that 10-day period
yeah
what about people who work in
supermarkets or people who work in
factories because we've heard from
people like marx and spencer
sainsbury's iceland they've they said
that they're on the knees and they don't
have enough staff working factories are
the same making our cars etc
are you going to have exemptions for
other key workers as well
so i just want to say to obviously key
workers and
businesses small medium and large is
that it is difficult
this is hard this is not a normal year
and the
uh nhs app has proven its worth saving
tens of thousands of lives hundreds of
thousands of people identified and asked
to isolate
it's an important clinical piece of
advice to people
who come into contact with someone who
has then tested
positive so it's important that we work
together
to try and get to the hopefully the 16th
of august when actually if you're double
vaccinated you don't need to
self-isolate and that will also help
businesses further
the reason for the for the for the gap
bring the exemptions forward are you
going to have exemptions for others
as well as or is it just going to be for
the nhs until the 16th of august
so at the moment it's for the nhs and
for social care staff these are
important
uh clinical care is incredibly important
at this uh any time i would suggest
but the 16th of august is also so
for the rest of the economy the reason
for the the gap is to allow more people
to be protected
with two doses we we've aimed to
get everyone protected with two doses by
the middle of
september if they've taken their uh dose
with
you know we've now met the target of
offering the vaccine to every adult
uh uh head of the 19th uh today
i think you've had three weeks this
morning i can't get a word in edgeways
uh tell me about the fact that by the
16th of august we might not have any
food on our shelves in the supermarkets
if this app keeps pinging away why won't
you look at other sectors as well
well as i said it's important that we
protect
the nhs and social care because
they're offering protection to the most
vulnerable people in our society
don't we minister i don't disagree with
you all i'm all i'm saying is
actually it's important that we work
together i think
businesses are rising to the challenge
many of them i know my colleagues
in the business department have been
talking to for example the
uh hospitality sector the entertainment
sector who are opening up
uh as of today where we're working with
them to make sure that they use the app
and by the way it's really worth noting
that since the 17th of may
okay when we develop the app uh pass
for the certification um six million
people have actually downloaded
the app in the last month two and a half
million people and they're not just
using it
for the covered bit they're using it to
order their uh
prescriptions over order and of course
gpa at work the chancellor when we have
story to interrupt we've only got a
little
bit of time left when we had the
chancellor uh in the back of our cab
last week
he said that you're going to be looking
at the sensitivity of the app
are you so when the app was developed
was developed in a world with no
vaccines
at all we're now as i said almost at 88
of all adults
having the vaccine we review the app all
the time
i think the important thing is that the
clinical advice to people if you've come
into contact with someone with covert
remains our priority through the app
that's the right thing to do
and then of course to make sure that we
continue to review the
the quality of that detection radar
system
all the time but we take nothing for
granted what i don't understand
minister is what you can do to change
the app because you know the app says if
you are within two meters of somebody
for
uh 15 minutes then you're going to have
to self isolate if they then suddenly
find themselves sadly with covid at home
so how can you actually change it how
can you change the sensitivity of it
no so what i'm trying to say to you is
is i think the right thing to do
is to continue to clinically advise
people
with that sensitivity that they have
come into contact with people
who have tested positive the difference
now
is that we've got almost 88 people with
one dose
and 68 of people with two doses
so we can take decisions like we've just
done um with the nhs and social care
staff
we can make decisions that on the 16th
of august
anyone who's double vaccinated doesn't
need to then
isolate if they are pinged and if they
don't test positive
for covert so those changes are
happening because of the vaccination
program
yeah um you were looking at vaccinating
some kids
why not all of them they're pesky little
super spreaders aren't they
so the joint committee on vaccination
and immunization
have just delivered their advice we'll
consider it in fact
after my morning round we have a covedo
and then i will make a statement to
parliament
but uh suffice to say they've looked
very closely especially at children
who are more vulnerable to serious
infection from covert
children who live with adults who are
more vulnerable serious infection from
covert and of course uh 17 year olds who
are close to
becoming 18 so three months from the
18th birthday and we will
take that advice on board and i'll make
a statement to parliament later today
and why not all the kids as i was saying
why not all children
so the jcbi are continuing to review
that
um there's now emerging data of children
all children being vaccinated in america
and elsewhere
with the first dose not yet enough data
with a second dose so they want to look
at
all the data there is a very rare signal
around something called myocarditis
which is an inflammation of the heart
and on balance um i think the jcbi
are coming down on the side of
continuing to review
all children healthy children but
actually wanting to protect the
vulnerable children first
okay just before i let you go on my way
to work this morning about
quarter to four there were an awful lot
of very relaxed young people
in central london um celebrating after
the clubs opened
at midnight last night when was the last
time you went to a club
oh my goodness what was the last time i
went to club probably
a couple of years ago um on holiday
uh but um
karaoke bar or something no there uh no
it was
it was it was a good club it was
actually a club and
i think it was in dubai but pretty
pretty um
uh impressive uh but nevertheless
sounds very racy for a minister of uh
the government
anyway the important thing okay is that
we're working
with nightclub operators uh to use
the covert app both for testing
and of course uh those who are
vaccinated so that we continue to safely
enjoy
uh nightclubbing in the united kingdom
the important thing is the businesses
and i know my business colleagues uh are
doing that paul scully's doing that
with the section at the moment well i
know a few clubs in london next time mrs
said is out of town give me a ring and
i'll i'll show you a good time minister
it's good to talk to you thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
you're on okay it's a deal